hey youtubers is Charlie so as promised
this is going to be my Game of Thrones
religious video so I want to talk about
some of the really big gods as well as
some of the really obscure ones - Martin
went to Toki and s clinks in developing
religions for the world of Song of Ice
and Fire
I'll start with the gods that the show
has done so far and then dive into some
of the other ones from the books some of
them are featured a lot more than others
the good thing is we can talk about
religions without getting too spoilery
for season 5 or for people that haven't
read books 4 or 5 but if you're just
finding me for the first time I'm doing
weekly Game of Thrones videos I'm also
doing that weekly book giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video just
in case general spoiler warning for
everything through season 4 on the show
I'll wait just a sec ok ready here we go
first is roller the red God thanks to
Melisandre and Thoros we know more about
him than almost any of the other gods
very important though that is not
implied that he is the most important
God it just he's been featured the most
roller is based on the real-world
Iranian religion of Manichaeism it's a
dualistic view of the world where you
have the god of light and goodness on
one side and the god of evil and
darkness on the other in the books
Melisandre calls roller the Lord of
Light and names his enemy the great
other the god of the White Walkers I
tend to think of the two of them is
existing in this yin and yang situation
where it's all about balance not so much
evil and good the show has presented
them and much more black and white terms
but I'm hoping future books like winds
of winter provide some more context
before we straight-up classify who's the
hero and who's the villain there's no
official start date for worship in
either of these gods but you can
consider them at least as old as the old
gods worship of the red God is much more
popular in the east and has started to
take hold in Westeros in a few groups
but corrosive Muir was actually sent
over to convert Aries the second the Mad
King and he absolutely was not convinced
Thoros was not successful
however Melisandre was successful in
turning Stannis in season 2 we saw him
burning the statues of the seven as a
way to show his newfound faith in the
red God so far on the show Melisandre
throws have been our conduit to the red
God you know how we learn new things
about him most of what we've seen so far
involved sacrificial rites to invoke a
blessing or gain visions or birthing
shadow creatures it's like you offer
something of high value and if the red
God favors you he grants you a vision or
an outcome or a shadow baby
the
Sergi can be men or women but not
everyone employed by the faith is a
priest their church buys children as
slaves and names them slaves of Roller
those people can go on to serve in the
red temples and have a number of jobs in
volantis there's actually this custom
were they tattoo the slaves faces with
flames it's not meant to be punitive
it's actually just a sign of their
servitude and it's viewed as an honor
organizationally there's a lot of
different jobs that people can have
there's priests temple prostitutes just
regular servants or temple guards so the
temple guards are actually called the
fiery hand they're not like an organized
military but they're pretty close to it
each of the organized faiths have their
own form of military you know maybe with
the exception of the old gods but
technically that's not an organized
religion general worship is organized
around red temples what they call their
churches there are seven known ones in
the world right now the biggest one is
enlist the reason Melisandre and Thoros
don't have those face tattoos though
even though they were probably slaves at
one point is probably just because they
did not live in volantis and a lot of
people are wondering where melis and
rose tattoos are hopefully in season 5
will be traveling around the East just a
little bit more in seeing a couple new
locations so we might see some of those
tattooed priests there are a lot of
notable characters in the novels inside
the faith of the red God that we haven't
seen on the show yet and since we don't
know what the show is going to include
I'm just gonna wait to talk about them
till the season starts some of them get
tied up in some of the bigger plots so I
don't wanna get too crazy with spoilers
but if you want to talk about them feel
free and just use spoiler tags in the
comments as the story of A Song of Ice
and Fire continues the religions
themselves become much bigger characters
for those that have read the books they
were trying to film this really notable
scene from book 4 in Dubrovnik around
this church but the local faith would
not let them do it this is the actual
production right now the producers have
found no workaround it's kind of funny
but if you want to talk about that
please also use spoiler tags in the
comments below but it just gives you an
idea of how the show as well as the
books start to focus more on the
religions as factions in general though
we start to see more influence from
various religions just like the iron
bank of Braavos became a big character
in season 4 some of the religions in the
world are just as powerful as the iron
bank the Church of the red God just
happens to be one of those one of the
really cool things about the right guy
though is that he has actually granted
powers to Melisandre and Thoros so we
know that he actually exists amongst the
prayers that he does
and include visions of the future
blessings on the outcome of encounters
or battles Shadow Puppets and a measure
of Resurrection so the important thing
to remember about Melisandre seeing
things in the flames and they're
completely subjective but it's like she
prays for certain things in the red God
sends her visions and she has to
interpret those so it's totally possible
for her to be wrong for example she
keeps telling Stannis that he is azor
Ahai but secretly I think that she
doesn't believe that and for those that
have read book 5 you know that when she
does look into the flames she sees
someone else altogether
remember spoiler tags in the comments I
think it's just evidence that the red
priests are every bit as normal as any
of the other characters
Thoros is a total drunk to boot and it's
also totally possible for red priests
like you know Thoris and Melisandre to
completely disagree on something so say
Melisandre found Ozora hi some other red
priests could say no this other person
is a Zora hi so they're not in complete
consensus on everything the one possible
exception to that is the belief in the
great other they all probably regardless
of you know who they think their Messiah
is believe that the great other is their
greatest enemy regardless of whether or
not he's evil he is the other half of
the dueling gods there are theories that
he's not the antagonist of the series
like it's possible that if there's a
final battle between the forces of fire
and ice the forces of the red God could
totally be the villains I did like a
whole video on that so I'll include a
link to that in the description the only
known followers of the great other are
the White Walkers that are also called
the others Melisandre calls them his
cold children which kind of makes you
think about the children of the forest
which is a completely different group
there's a rumor that the three-eyed
Raven who's kind of associated with the
children of the forest is a servant of
the great other that's the person that
bran met in the finale
that's not confirmed or anything it's
just another theory from the show that's
open to interpretation so like I said
there's no known start date for that
dualistic religion but the White Walkers
are known to have appeared about 8,000
years before Aegon's conquest there's
been no indication that they have any
form of hierarchy but the show did
supposedly do the night's king who's
supposedly some sort of white Walker
leader although there's some debate as
to whether or not that was an error of
the show like they call it the night's
king in error they're not really an
organized religion though you can think
of them more as a species
if you look at what the show presented
it appears that White Walkers turn
humans to their power as children and
adults they simply just kill and
reanimate as corpses to be used as
infantry but the next big group of
deities are the old gods or you call
them the gods of the forest their power
is represented in although we're woods
in the north most of the weirwoods have
been cut down in the south so it's
thought that they don't have power down
there anymore and it's similar is a lot
of these deities sound I think that
they're distinct I think the old gods
are different from roller who's
different from the great other I don't
think it's all the same God the closest
thing that the old gods have to clerics
and priests are the children of the
force in the green seers who we've
really only just met on the show
supposedly bran is becoming a green seer
or he is one we don't really know how
many children of the forest are left
alive but presumably we're gonna see
more in season five hopefully unless
they totally drop brand story most of
the humans who worship or worshiped the
old gods were from the north like the
first men but now typically the only
people that follow them are the free
folk in the Starks like the people that
still live in the far north they really
don't have a lot of ceremonies or
customs other than saying prayers in the
godswood where the heart trees are those
are we're woods with the faces drawn on
them that exists inside the castles of
Westeros but most of them have been
chopped down it's believed that the
trees are the old gods who have died and
become part of the great God's wood
that's like the massive interconnected
root system that supposedly runs
throughout the planet you actually kind
of get a glimpse of this root system
whenever they travel into that cave the
three-eyed Raven like I said I don't
know how much a brand story they're
going to include next season but
presumably we'll learn more about this
root system and how all the weirwoods
are connected and hopefully we'll learn
whether or not the three-eyed Raven is
associated with the great other because
that would actually be a really big deal
in Westeros the old gods were the
primary faith until the Andals invaded
and brought the faith of the seven I
guess you could think of that as being
like the Catholic Crusades
although the Andals appear to have been
far more successful and taking over and
converting the first men then the
Catholics were with Islam but like I
said since the Andal invasion most of
the weirwoods in the south have been cut
down thus the old gods have no more
power there anymore so the next big
group is the faith of the seven they're
basically like the main religion of
Westeros and they're going to be really
big in season five they actually
just cast the high septon which is kind
of like the Pope think of the religion
is being like the Greek polytheistic
pantheon only in practice working a lot
more like traditional Christianity in
terms of organized worship there are
seven gods but people can pray to any of
the seven gods based on what they're
praying for there's the father who
represents judgment he's depicted as a
bearded man carrying scales people pray
to him for justice there's the mother
who represents motherhood and nurturing
she's depicted by a woman smiling with
love people pray to her for fertility
and compassion then there's the warrior
who represents strength and battle he
looks like a soldier carrying a sword
people pray to him for courage and
victory then there's the maiden who
represents innocence people pray to her
to protect women's virginity and virtue
then there's a Smith who represents the
crafting arts and manual labor he looks
like a blacksmith carrying a hammer he's
played to whenever they're doing work or
big things are being built
then there's the Crone who represents
wisdom she looks like an old woman
carrying a lantern people pray to her
for guidance and then there's the
stranger who represents death in the
unknown he's kind of a creepy God
usually the only people that pray to him
are outcasts and assassins they do have
a Bible it's called the seven pointed
star seven points for seven gods it
tells a really interesting origin story
for the religion supposedly the seven
originally walked on earth in human form
in the father brought down seven stars
from the sky and used them to form the
crown of Hugh gore of the hill he was
the first king of the Andals and the
rest of the other gods origin stories
are kind of tied up in aspects of Hugo's
rise to power it gets kind of funny if
you examine it real closely it sounds
almost like Hugh Gore United the Andals
and then people created a religion
around him so of all the gods in A Song
of Ice and Fire the seven at least in my
opinion sound the most false that
doesn't mean that they are but whenever
a religions based on a king telling
everyone how awesome he is it just
brings a little bit false in Westeros
the faith got so powerful that they
developed their own military it started
a civil war eventually it ended in the
Targaryen Kings banned them from ever
taking up arms again structurally the
churches organized a lot like the
Catholic Church you know you have
SEPTA's septons in the High Septon their
main church is called the great Sept of
Baelor in King's Landing it's the
building where Sansa was married to
Tyrion and Joffrey was married to
Margaery so the show has already been
there there are a lot more sex and sub
groups inside the church but it is one
of the most complicated religions in
Westeros so I'll spend a lot more time
talking about it whenever we get into
the season they're military though is
actually really interesting it was
called the faith militant it's featured
heavily in book four so if you do want
to learn about them before season five
be sure to read feast for crows and
please use spoiler tags we're going to
comment about them I know I just implied
that the seven might be a little bit
bogus but in the Iron Islands they
worship the drowned God he's just as old
as the old gods and I do think that he
has some power just like the old gods
Roller and the great other the drowned
God predated the Andal invasion and
because the original Ironborn were a
pirate culture their worship kind of
rose up around those practices so
supposedly the drown God wants them to
rape and pillage and make great
conquests in his name the interesting
thing is that the drown God also exists
in a dualistic nature with the storm God
one above the sea the other below one of
their big customs is that whenever a new
follower is anointed or baptized they
forcibly drowned him like he actually
dies for a little while than they
resuscitated after that they can go on
to become priests or just live normal
lives but the priests are known as the
drowned men like that's what their name
is their big saying is what is dead may
never die and a lot of that's tied up
when with the fact that they've been
drowned and literally killed like
they're literally dead people that
doesn't mean that they're zombies or
anything but I have a feeling that that
belief kind of arose from the idea that
sailors died all the time and it just
became a coping mechanism the last big
religion in Westeros is Reuter their God
is the mother Roy and it's practiced
mostly in the south most parts of the
kingdom like Dorne so presumably we'll
see a little bit of it whenever we visit
that place in season five there DeeDee
is a river goddess but the river that
she's based on exists in the east
whenever those followers migrated to
Dorne they just brought it with them but
the big river that runs through Dorne is
called the green blood so most of the
practices of that religion live along
the river so moving along back to the
East Braavos is one of the most
interesting religious places on the show
or in the novel's just because there's a
greater diversity of deities worshipped
there than in any other place in the
world aside from the other major deities
who are all worshiped there the most
infamous one is the many-faced God the
one that the faceless men worship in
total there are more than 18 separate
deities with shrine
or temples inside the city that people
worship to that number includes some of
the ones that I've already mentioned but
some of the more obscure ones include a
quand the red bull back Alon the great
shepherd the hooded Wayfarer the horse
God that's actually the god of the
Dothraki the lady of the spears that's
actually the god of the unsullied the
Merlyn King the moon pale Maiden the
pattern
semaj and solo so who are actually twin
gods the silent God the stone cow of
Pharaoh's trios and the weeping lady of
lists the are filming scenes in Braavos
for season five so hopefully they'll
show some of this diversity but the show
does not get really deep with the
mechanics of religion so don't expect
like really big explainers aside from
maybe some of the major religions in
real life george RR martin based all
these gods and religions just on a
mishmash of real-life historical ones
like animism catholicism polytheism and
norse mythology
right now i'll say that the red god is
probably my favorite because he's
presented as being so benevolent but he
seems so sinister and then you look at
his enemy the great other who's
presented as being very sinister but who
we know almost nothing about supposedly
wins a winter is going to change that
though so get excited so i'm gonna do a
Q&A for this video be sure to subscribe
to get it i'll post it tomorrow my next
bonus video is probably going to be
about the civil war that rose up between
the faith militant and the Targaryen
Kings just because I feel like that's
going to be something that the show is
going to deal with so I think it's gonna
be really interesting
in the meantime click here to get that
Q&A I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it and click here to learn about my
top five prophecies on the show thank
you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives
Oh